[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité
avec à la une la solidarité des
territoires français qui s'organisent
pour accueillir des réfugiés les
ukrainiens dans les yvelines des jeunes
sont déjà hébergé et peuvent envisager
ainsi leur avenir un peu plus
sereinement vous verrez un reportage de
tv 78 dès le début de ce journal lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire et
rendre accessible fruits et légumes
c'est l'objectif d'une belle initiative
en bretagne dans le finistère des
aliments qui devait être jeté à la
poubelle sont revendus pour 5 euros
seulement une bonne action que nous fera
découvrir les chaînes tv aux tv sud les
chaînes du groupe le télégramme
les pèlerins sont de retour à lourdes la
ville fortement affectée par deux années
de restrictions liées à la pandémie voit
les visiteurs revenir progressivement
une très bonne nouvelle pour l'ensemble
de l'écosystème local nous expliquera
télé7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest sa
pause hivernale est presque terminée le
petit rat de l'awt sommes presque
centenaire est actuellement en pleines
révisions passionnés et professionnels
prennent soin de ses treize tonnes
d'acier en vue du début de la saison
touristique
reportage enfin d'édition de wow tv la
chaîne de la voix du nord
mais on débute donc ce journal avec la
guerre en ukraine qui dure maintenant
depuis plus d'une semaine après la
surprise lié à l'ampleur de la tacc
l'heure est à la riposte désormais
sanctions internationales contre les
autorités russes et les institutions
financières notamment mais aussi l'exode
pour beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui
cherchaient à fuir les combats il
pourrait être à terme plusieurs millions
à quitter le pays pour y faire face
l'europe s'organise pour accueillir les
réfugiés dans les meilleures conditions
en france les premières réfugiés sont
déjà arrivés comme dans les yvelines ou
le département héberge des jeunes
ukrainiens à reportage de tv 78 la
chaîne des yvelines
voilà la lettre adressée par le préfet
jean jacques brot au maire des yvelines
une demande de recensement des offres
d'hébergement
chaque commune a reçu ce tableau qui
devrait être envoyée à la préfecture
objectif centraliser les propositions
d'accueil de famille ukrainienne fuyant
leur pays nous allons et une
centralisation quelque sorte pour ses
offres
d'hébergement de sorte qu'elle soit bien
connu identifié on les fera remonter au
niveau national et dès qu'il y aura des
arrivées on fera des appariements entre
le type de logement sa situation sera
pas ses proximités avec un moyen de
transport etc et les besoins des
familles au cas par cas dans la mesure
du possible je recommande que ces
propositions de logement d'hébergement
soit accompagnée de propositions
d'accompagnement c'est très important
que on n'ajoute pas au déracinement à
l'exil à la crainte de la guerre et de
ses conséquences en plus une situation
d'isolement dans les yvelines en france
officiellement il n'ya pas encore
d'arriver dans les yvelines mais des
ukrainiens déjà présent en france au
moment du déclenchement de la guerre
sont accueillis au campus des mureaux
huit jeunes au total âgés de 16 à 39 ans
nous assurons à ce jeune le gîte et le
couvert il va falloir aussi une aide
d'urgence pour qu'il puisse habiller son
parti pour quelques jours donc avec
quelques vêtements il va falloir aussi
leur trouver une activité
des activités rémunératrices parce
qu'ils n'ont rien
des activités tout court de la formation
en particulier d'information la mystique
il faut qu'ils apprennent le français
par ailleurs des commune yvelinoise se
mobilisent déjà en proposant des
collectes vêtements produits d'hygiène
ou encore literie des points de dons
sont mises en place notamment à poissy
aux mureaux ou encore à carrières sous
poissy
et un message d'espoir en ces temps de
conflit qui va de pair avec la
solidarité dont font preuve les français
à limoges les pompiers de l'urgence
internationale une ong créée par le
colonel philippe besson s'occupe de la
logistique nécessaires pour l'envoi de
produits de première nécessité aux
frontières de l'ukraine matériel médical
médicaments produits d'hygiène la
municipalité a ouvert quant à elle un
site de dépôt volontaire le maire a
également mises à la disposition de
l'état l'ancien bâtiment d'un ehpad en
cas de besoin d'hébergement un reportage
d'alain druot pour 7 à limoges à limoges
la solidarité vers le peuple ukrainien
se met en place une collecte
produits de première nécessité a été
lancée dans le hall de l'hôtel de ville
les pompiers de l'urgence internationale
organisation dont le siège est
limougeaud assure la logistique qui
parce qu'on a reçu pas mal de dons de
particuliers voire même d'entreprise il
faut qu'on reprenne quand même les dons
pour les mettre hors catégorie dont tu
as par exemple on va faire un carton que
de perfusion un autre qu'avec des
perfuseurs en train de prier non les
médicaments par type anti coagulantes
les abattoirs quatre mandats douleur et
cetera on trie également les vêtements
les cognements des bébés les litiges et
la municipalité a mis à disposition de
l'état une ancienne maison de retraite
vide d'occupants depuis déjà quelques
semaines gala disposition des réfugiés
si nous en avions c'est bien peu de
chose est bien là qui sens où les bandes
mieux de la guerre qui vont souffrir les
populations qui se déplace eh bien la
moindre des choses c'est nous que nous
puissions leur transmettre ce que nous
avons qui peut leur servir initialement
prévue jusqu'en milieu de semaine la
collecte devrait être prolongé alors
qu'une première expédition vient d'être
lancé a eu tellement de succès est un
petit peu submergé par les dons dans les
trois entités donc on devait faire mon
départ un semi remorque par organisation
et je pense que parti comme si on va se
retrouver avec peut-être une dizaine de
sperme en des points de collecte sont
également en place à caen et valence les
palettes seront regroupés à lyon jeudi
vendredi de départ immédiat
la situation en ukraine qui a été
largement évoquée avec jean marc ayrault
lors de l'émission face aux territoires
jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde l'ancien
premier ministre qui était encore à
matignon lors du début de la crise de
2014 et de l'annexion de la crimée
écoutez son avis quant à la situation
actuelle y at il tout de même une
responsabilité des grands leaders de nos
gouvernants dont vous avez fait partie
dont vous faites partie depuis on va
dire plus d'une décennie qui n'ont pas
su déceler qui n'ont pas su voir qu'ils
étaient devenus vladimir poutine
il faudra beaucoup de recul pour pour
comprendre tout ce qui a conduit à cette
tragédie parce que c'est une tragédie
pour le peuple ukrainien dont poutine
dit qu'il n'existe pas est en fait la
nation ukrainienne réagi se défend avec
dignité et avec courage au prix de 2
lors de la vie de beaucoup de gens et
quand vous avez regardé plein manger
routine dans les yeux c'était assez
froid mais sans agressivité au départ
mais très vite ça l'est devenu ça l'est
devenu il y avait un sujet qui préoccupe
est et qui était centrale dans la
rencontre c'était l'ukraine déjà
l'ukraine à cette époque était envisagée
dans les jours qui suivaient ma visite
une réunion de l'union européenne et de
l'ukraine pour signer un accord
d'association
d'association entre l'ukraine et l'union
européenne et poutine n'en voulait pas
et agressé m'agresser agacé la france
agressé l'europe à 10 ans et en termine
en disant ça ne se fera pas cet accord
ne sera pas signée en fait il n'a pas
été saigné puisque le ianoukovitch le
président ukrainien proche de moscou a
cédé à ma poutine
l'émission face aux territoires avec
jean marc ayrault est à voir ou à revoir
sur les sites internet de tv5monde de
ouest-france et de nice matin dans le
reste de l'actualité l'inquiétude de
certains éleveurs dans le gère les
gérants d'exploitation de volailles sont
confrontés depuis plusieurs mois à un
épisode de grip arrière une maladie qui
les oblige à confiner leurs animaux même
si certains vous allez le voir ont du
mal à se faire à cette idée il
s'inquiète pour le bien-être de leurs
animaux c'est le cas de nicolas petit
éleveur bio installé à och écoutez le au
micro de matisse gardant journaliste à
la dépêche du midi nos partenaires
avec la restriction des espaces on a
touché en fait le fondement même de ma
façon d'élever et je peux pas travailler
en bio avec des petites cabanes sur des
petits élevages arboré avec des parcours
à rebours et j'ai vraiment du mal en
fait à faire appliquer cette
réglementation il ya 500 poulets et ils
sont élevées sur
deux mille mètres carrés de plein air à
partir de l'âge de 5 semaines
aujourd'hui elles sont sur un parcours
restreint de 250 m² ça veut dire moins
de 15 % de ce que je leur donnais avant
donc moi ça me pose un problème puisque
on va perdre le bénéfice du plein air
chaque année plus de 900 millions de
tonnes de nourriture sont gaspillées
dans le monde soit près de 20% des
aliments disponibles pour nous nourrir
un paradoxe alors que certains peinent à
acheter des légumes alors pour lutter
contre le phénomène est bien à breton a
lancé il ya peu une initiative sont non
finis tes reste 29 un concept de
cagettes de légumes anti-gaspillage à 5
euros des carottes des champignons des
poireaux sauver de la benne à ordures le
concept se développe aujourd'hui partout
en bretagne
un succès est une belle initiative que
nous raconte valérie leroux coléno pour
la rédaction de tv sud les chaînes du
groupe le télégramme
ces pannes s et potirons ses carottes
sont un peu des rescapés c'est ce qu'on
appelle les fameuses écart doté pour
fois copti soit trop et ils vont des
cicatrices sur la peau et donc tous ces
produits là ne font pas ne pourront pas
avoir à déboucher dans la grande
distribution qui chaque jour dans ce
hangar de saint-pol-de-léon il en arrive
dix tonnes en provenance d'exploitation
du secteur situé à moins de 20 km c'est
à force de voir tous ces produits aptes
à la consommation partir à la poubelle
que cet ancien salarié d'une grande
coopérative agricole sur un coup de
coeur ou plutôt un coup de griffe cup
dans mon garage j'ai fait une
cinquantaine de cagettes je me suis dit
on va le faire à 5 euros pour
démocratiser prix des légumes j'avais
pas de commerce donc j'ai pris ma
camionnette et je me suis appuyé sur
deux applications la première qui
s'appelle tout mou tout la deuxième qui
s'appelle fénix
premier jour j'ai eu en client donc le
lendemain j'ai eu 120 panier aujourd'hui
trois mois après s'être relancé l'équipe
devant 2000 pagny par jour pour ses
cagettes direction des quatre coins de
la bretagne comme ici à ergué gabéric
cet entrepôt ont ouvert hier soir avant
l'ouverture à 17h30 il y avait déjà la
queue 6000 abonnés sur facebook c'est
une véritable communauté qui s'est créé
sur les réseaux sociaux 30 commerçants
les ventes aujourd'hui les paniers anti
gaspi l120 paniers sont parties en une
demi journée ça m'apporte un flux de
clientèle que je n'aurais pas sûrs en
temps normal l'aventuré aurait aussi
permis de créer une vingtaine d'emplois
il prévoit bientôt de développer l' anti
gaspi pour les fruits et les oeufs bio
qui sont parfois jetés à défaut de
trouver une place dans les rayons de la
grande distribution
faut-il interdire la chasse le week-end
le débat est relancé depuis le drame
survenu dans le cantal il y a deux
semaines et le décès d'une jeune
randonneuse de 25 ans dans la loire pour
éviter les accidents chasseurs et
randonneurs coopèrent et s'échangent des
informations
ils ont même signé une convention la
formule ne semble marcher localement
écouter ses propos recueillis par adrien
bletterie pour tl7 la chaîne de la loire
on a passé une convention du bien vivre
ensemble donc il n'ya pas de souci quand
on quand on voit les randonnées dans un
endroit quand un groupe qui est fédérée
donc qui appartient à la fédération de
la loire veut aller randonner dans un
endroit et il sait qu'il ya une risque
d'y avoir une chasse ce jour-là une
battue en particulier un envoi le
circuit que l'on va faire la date à
laquelle on va y aller pour prévenir la
fédération de chasse donc que nous on va
aller sur ce terrain et s'il ya une
battue il faudrait prévenir les
chasseurs qui chassent à cet endroit là
et c'est ce qui se passe
partons dans le sud-ouest à présent où
le sanctuaire notre dame de lourdes et
suit depuis trois ans une crise
économique sans précédent du fait de la
pandémie le nombre de visiteurs a baissé
de 95 % en 2020 avec l'annulation des
pèlerinages mais aussi la fermeture de
sa fameuse grotte heureusement le site a
rouvert il ya presque un mois la ville
quant à elle bénéficiera d'une aide de
100 millions d'euros sur place alix
fourcade de tv7 de la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
touchés le rocher aller boire à la
source et s'il avait pendant deux ans
les visiteurs de lourdes se sont vus
refuser d'effectuer les gestes du
pèlerin à cause de la crise sanitaire la
célèbre grotte où bernadette soubirous
et ses apparitions de la vierge dans la
religion catholique était fermé elle
vient de rouvrir le 11 février dernier
comme c'est un lieu vraiment culte de
lourdes on veut vraiment venir voir ce
que c'était de nos grands mères sont
croyantes du coup nous ni leur cherche
un peu d'eau la grotte m'avait manqué je
trouve que la fermeture de la grotte ce
n'était plus lourde en fait avant la
crise sanitaire le sanctuaire de lourdes
a accueilli en moyenne 3,5 millions de
visiteurs en 2020 ce nombre a chuté de
95% et de 70% en 2021 on espère que
l'année 2022 redeviendra non pas normal
mais une année de pèlerinage en tant que
tel avec des processions deux fois par
jour vous savez ce flot de lumière de
procession aux flambeaux confronté un
véritable crash économique la ville a
bénéficié d'un premier plan de relance
de 176 millions d'euros entre 2020 et
2021 auquel vient désormais s'ajouter un
plan à venir sur dix ans de 100 millions
d'euros annoncée sur place par le
premier ministre jean castex la semaine
dernière on va requalifier la ville en
terme de l'attractivité d'esthétisation
de projets structurants on va travailler
sur des filières on va profiter aussi de
l'espace naturel que soient les pyrénées
puisque nous sommes à la porte des pays
des gaves s'engager dans une ville aussi
on a on a plaisir à venir parce que
c'est aussi la ville de la paix celle du
malade et du handicap mais avant
l'avenir c'est le présent qui inquiète
surtout les commerçants du centre ville
avec la baisse des fréquentations leurs
ventes ont chuté je vois beaucoup de
commerçants qui viennent me voir qui me
disent comment on va faire pour toi je
vis je ne sais pas mais il faut tenir et
encore on a tenu grâce aux aides de
l'état faut pas oublier que si on
n'avait pas eu les aides de l'état
il y aurait beaucoup plus de cas ce que
clive à l'illiade à voir megan aura
forcément tous attendent donc
impatiemment le mois d'avril où les
pèlerinages doivent reprendre
progressivement
et on part pour les antilles en
martinique c'est le carnaval qui était
de retour ces jours-ci dans les rues de
fort de france pour le plus grand
bonheur de tous un carnaval historique
est synonyme de bonne humeur de danse de
couleurs et de fanfare comme vous le
voyez sur ces images de loïc régis et de
lhuis sa basse de la rédaction locale de
via à tv martine
voilà de belles images qui ravit
évidemment les martiniquais et qui nous
remonte le moral à nous aussi en
métropole de la chaleur de la martinique
aux froides de la norvège le grand jt
des territoires vous amène à la
découverte d'un me choque pas comme les
autres antoine gamin vient de participer
avec ses chiens à l'une des courses les
plus difficiles de sa discipline en
norvège un mois dans le grand nord dans
des conditions climatiques évidemment
très compliqué et peu de sommeil pour
parcourir 170 km par jour une expérience
d au moins inoubliable pour lui et sa
meute d'alaska noski cessons donc à
reportage d'aurélie colombelles pour vos
jeux télévision regarde
650 km de piste balayée par des vents
importants - 15 - 20 degrés le vosgien
antoine gamin est arrivé 20e à la ferme
une la course longue distance en
chiens de traîneaux qui s'est tenue il
ya quelques semaines autour du lac de
fairmount en norvège c'est la première
fois sur cette distance
on s'inscrit nous on veut entrer qui
n'est en fait pas la compétition on va
enfin le but pour nous c'est d'arriver
au bout et sur les irakiens donc on a
réussi et en plus ça on a fait une place
qui n'était finalement pas trop mal de
retour à cornimont les chiens retrouve
une vie plus calme d'autant plus qu'avec
les chaleurs des chiennes antoine a dû
se résoudre à attacher la meute treize
des vingt à l'as cannes ski issus du
croisement des deux races ont participé
aux quatre jours de course une épreuve
physique qui multiplie par dix leurs
besoins en nourriture pour faire 170 km
par jour c'est 17 heures de déplacement
malgré la nuit très longue dans ce pays
septentrionale
la difficulté ça a été le sommeil pour
moi c'est vrai que on dort très peu sur
ce type d'épreuve on est de l'ordre de
deux à trois heures par 24 heures donc
c'est quand même pas beaucoup on court
on est comme aussi beaucoup les chiens
donc c'est assez fatigant un défi
sportif qui lui a fait perdre 10 kilos
en un mois antoine dormait dehors avec
ses chiens malgré les conditions
climatiques notamment avec daphné c'est
ma chaîne préférée c'est ma chaîne de
tête et donc une chaîne qui est très
intelligent qui écoutent très bien donc
c'est vraiment toutes mes courses on les
a fait toutes les grandes courses elle
est en tête et c'est elle qui dirige l
attelage le musher consacre un budget de
12 à 15 mille euros par an pour sa meute
une passion coûteuse qu'ils financent
grâce à des activités annexes comme les
balades pour les touristes
le printemps c'est dans trois semaines
mais antoine et ses chiens attendent
déjà avec impatience l'hiver prochain
pour retrouver ce paradis blanc où l'on
aperçoit encore rennes sauvages grand et
rae lan ou perdrix des neiges
des jeux paralympiques d'hiver ils ont
débuté ce week-end à pékin jusqu'au 13
mars pas moins de 600 sportifs venus du
monde entier vont s'affronter dans près
de 80 épreuves à cette occasion la
station de tignes met à l'honneur le
handiski au pied des pistes plusieurs
ateliers permettent le temps d'une
descente de s'initier à des pratiques
peu commune les bras dans le dos ou les
yeux bandés de nombreux courageux sont
attendus pour tester la piste des
champions emmanuel jo de la rédaction de
8 mo blanc est déjà un de ses champions
regardez son reportage
la
passion à droite droite
mme équilibrer la confiance c'est tout
de suite moins naturel sans le sens de
la vue afin de mieux se rendre compte de
l'engagement nécessaire à la pratique du
hand içki le groupe edf organise le
temps d'une semaine une véritable
immersion sensorielle sur les pistes une
nouvelle expérience pour les nombreux
curieux qui se sont prêtés au jeu alors
c'est une belle découverte moi qui ai de
bonnes sensations habituellement à la
c'est vrai que c'est déroutant mais très
plaisant et je pense que ça demande un
sacré engagement avec un slalom les bras
dans le dos et une initiation au ski
fauteuil cette animation baptisée la
piste des champions connaît déjà un
franc succès dans la station savoyarde
une opération sur laquelle se sont aussi
essayé plusieurs athlètes du team edf
bah c'est hyper intéressant parce que on
se rend pas du tout content fait à quel
point c'est perturbant surtout la
déficience visuelle là c'est vraiment
autant le slalom sont les bâtons ça va
parce qu'on voit en fait partiellement
on voit plus on n'a plus de repères et
du cou
c'est vraiment pas facile c'est vraiment
ne pas savoir faire on sait pas si on
arrêtait pas arrêté voilà du coup
heureusement qu'elle guide si l'appel
guide c'est impossible
en corse les sauveteurs prépare déjà la
saison touristique la société nationale
de sauvetage en mer de calvi vient de
réaliser une formation de plusieurs
jours à destination de ses bénévoles
objectif les former au sujet
d'hypothermie des personnes secourues et
à la nage de jour comme de nuit comme
vous allez le voir un stage pour le
moins intensif comme a pu s'en rendre
compte la rédaction devient telle est
pas aisé sur place propos collectées par
clara marley et noah t as qu
il ya beaucoup de formation comment
utiliser et connaître le type de
matériel qu'elle soit d'un filin nageurs
d'une barquette dans quelles conditions
ils utilisent et comment le mettre en
oeuvre et surtout là le point essentiel
la coordination entre la personne qui va
utiliser et l'équipage c'est pourquoi on
utilise donc cette formation qui dure
sur quatre jours qui est quand même
assez c'est le forte c'est costaud on
peut dire parce que aider les stagiaires
et nous aussi on reste dans l'eau du
matin jusqu'au soir
mais aussi se prépare pour les touristes
le petit train de la haute somme est
actuellement en pleines révisions
aménagement des voies révision de la
locomotive à vapeur tous les bénévoles
sont sur le pont pour s'assurer que tout
va bien pour ce train presque centenaire
le début de la saison touristique est
prévu pour le week-end du 17 avril
prochain et jérôme ouvrons nous montre
la voie pour la chaîne ou et aux tv la
chaîne de la voix du nord
plus qu'un mois avant l'heure du départ
dans son atelier bastien donne les
derniers coups de marteau et inspectent
la mécanique d'une locomotive à vapeur
de 1925 là il reste encore à monter tout
l'embiellage donc l'embiellage je sais
les parties métalliques qu'on voit c'est
ça qu'on voit bouger quand la locomotive
roule donc c'est ce qui rejoint tous les
tout l'hérault cette dame presque
centenaire vient d'aix allemagne de
l'est 13 tonnes d'acier qui tractait
autrefois les voyageurs de berre l'un à
la frontière polonaise depuis cette
raison bastien révise réparé restaure ce
prototype classé monument historique
c'est souvent l'occasion pour lui d'en
retracer le parcours quand la restaure
hongre à toute la peinture et c'est là
qu'on peut découvrir des gravures donc
on retrouve des dates on retrouve des
noms de des prénoms on retrouve des noms
de d'ateliers s'est retrouvé un petit
bout d'histoire gravé sur le châssis ou
sur ou sur les différents éléments de la
locomotive à quelques kilomètres de là
des petites mains s'affairent à
restaurer près de 650 mètres de voies
ferrées remplacer les traverses
s'assurer de l'écartement des rails oui
même hors saison le petit train de la
haute somme c'est du boulot les gens
nous voient quand on roule en saison
elles ont la patience et tous les jours
dimanche mais derrière tout ça il ya
énormément de travail
l'hiver travail de voix travail de
maintenance à la sueur de leur front les
bénévoles préserve et transmettent ce
fragment d'histoire l'histoire d'une
ligne ferroviaire franco britannique
construite en 1915 pour préparer la
bataille de la somme et alimenter le
front en munitions d'artillerie c'est
important pour nous de dire attendez
vous êtes en train d'emprunter un train
historique de la première guerre
mondiale derrière il n'y avait pas que
des gens aient tiré au fusil qu'avec des
canons il y avait tout ce qui alimente
est derrière qui a alimenté le feu était
en première ligne en mai les touristes
pourront à nouveau emprunter les rails
de la neuville lès bray à dompierre pour
un voyage de sept kilomètres dans le
temps en attendant il reste aux
bénévoles un long chemin à faire avant
d'entendre siffler le train
[Musique]
direction monaco pour refermer cette
édition du grand jt des territoires
maintenant l'un des casinos de la
principauté accueilli il y a quelques
jours un tournoi d'échecs les
compétiteurs de jeu enfance sont
notamment opposés à deux championnes de
la discipline et au prince albert de
monaco retour sur l'événement avec
sandrine negra de monaco à chauray
s est simultané prince albert 1er a
débuté en présence d'un joueur
prestigieux le prince albert ii qui a
donné le premier coup symbolique sur ces
échiquier face à lui 32 jeunes joueurs
qui ont ensuite poursuivi leur partie
avec deux championnes dont pia crumbling
qui a d'ailleurs reçu la coupe a salué
un premier album en
t'attendant
ma propre enfance et quand j'ai
rencontré un grand maître pour la
première fois ça c'était une sorte de
divinité
je pense que ce sont les souvenirs
qu'elle sent extrêmement délicieux sacré
et cet événement autour du noble jeu
dans l'atrium du casino faisait ainsi
écho au prince albert 1er qui était
conscient du rayonnement apportées par
les échecs 1901
en 1904 il ya eu des grands prix d'échec
dans le casino de monte carlo avec les
meilleurs joueurs du monde étaient
présents et ensuite on a rejoué aux
échecs dans les salons du casino au
salon 12 et en 2015
c'était donc grand prix féminin d'échec
et pierre g league et ea mirage que
celle qu ils étaient déjà présentes et
ont participé à ce grand prix féminin
nous avons établi un pont entre le passé
et le présent et le futur avec ses
jeunes joueurs qui sont présents et des
correspondants deux des plus grands
journaux étrangers étaient là et en des
comptes chaque jour des parties à une
époque à la belle époque où le noble jeu
était tenu en haute estime pour ses
valeurs morales intellectuelles humaine
et diamants des valeurs qui sont
d'actualité comme en témoigne le succès
rencontré par la série le jeu de la dame
où les tomes du manga made in monaco sur
les échecs blitz
voilà et puis je ne voudrais pas à
refermer ce journal sans un mot pour
jean pierre pernaut qui nous a quittés
mercredi c'était le pionnier de
l'information de proximité au revoir
jean pierre pernaut voilà c'est la fin
de ce en gîte et des territoires merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]